do you love odd one out
did you know that every purchase at the
jubilee shop helps fund this show
if you're looking for ways to support
jubilee and watch more episodes of odd
one out make sure you check out our
merch at shop.jublymedia.com
now enjoy this episode as far as recent
trends what have your favorite trends
been the musically how they're like
bringing musically black is with the
doji cat song yeah
we brought together seven gen z i'm gen
z i'm gen z i'm genji i'm gen z i'm
gentee i'm gen z i'm gen z
one is a millennial if the group
discovers who the liar is they'll split
a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
prize
who is the odd one out
[Music]
bro my heart's beating so fast here's my
favorite movies growing up childhood
movies king kong
charlie the chocolate factory uh easy a
was one of my favorites mine was
hairspray high school musical sorry
anyway yeah yeah keep going musical high
school musical or camp rock camp rock
any any disney series okay she seemed
older and more mature than the rest of
us she was also asking a lot of
questions off the bat so i was like hmm
something's going on there too we should
say how old we are i'm 19. i'm 21. i'm
22. i'm 19. i'm 24. i'm 23. i'm 22. wait
am i the youngest one here yeah sure is
everybody on tick tock right now yeah
okay as far as recent trends what have
your favorite trends been oh anything
dozier cat okay i love her the musically
how they're like bringing musically
black it's with the doji cat song
go down the line i'm trying to think of
the one i don't know i watch a lot of
dogs so i'm trying to think of the one
um
no gen z person talks about dog videos
so that was a little bit suspicious to
me do you guys use facebook at all only
to like sell things on marketplace
and for the grandparents because they
don't understand
polite okay
kind of pretty lighting
[Music]
always trust your gut he looked too
young like there was just something
about him
alyssa just seemed to like ask like a
lot of questions that were like trying
to like take attention off of herself
[Music]
i love your sweater thank you i think
that maybe they were intimidated about
the confidence and my questions i should
have stayed quiet for the first round
what's like y'all's like favorite type
of music um i'm really into r b hip-hop
daniel caesar's is a
top artist i was in a lot of hip-hop and
alternative so okay i'm like very
generic pop music i don't know a lot
about music so yeah country or very
generic pop like dosha cat for sure yeah
when she said country music i just don't
think of that as a very like the like
gen z thing to say so it just seemed to
me as if she was trying to like
pretend does everyone have a job yes
okay what does everyone do i'm a hostess
okay and a speed runner yeah i work in
travel nurse recruiting so during covid
we recruited nurses to go to hospitals
oh nice cool i'm a music teacher
oh
i mean i teach like uh like one-on-one
off lessons like about piano
violin lessons singing lessons okay so
like you're it picked up a lot in covid
like that was like the finding zoom
lessons do you have to like go through a
lot of like qualifications in school um
i got a qualification through like a
private section like uh i'm just a while
ago
it was like six months it wasn't that
long but i studied music at school so
like it was not like a how long did you
study music in school four years four
years yeah i went to
graduated 2019 like right before as 24 i
was the oldest person in the box and so
i was nervous that they were going to
pre
like eliminate me early where do you
guys shop oh
i shop at zara and urban outfitters
money sauce
i'm so i'm a very like against fast
fashion so i like buffalo exchange is
like the really good thrift shop that's
kind of la so like that's really good i
love target
favorite
um or my roommate's closet shopping her
closet there genzie's usually dressed
like with like uh chunky sneakers or
like baggier pants or like looser pants
like not like cargo shorts or like
bomber jackets or something like that oh
what's your favorite cartoon growing up
oh my god the last airbender
regular show jimmy neutron probably yeah
someone said nickelodeon chess kids next
door was mine but i was gonna ask you
all right
um
disney channel cartoon network or
nickelodeon
network cartoon network i think i was
more disney
[Music]
i really want to be your friend though
when he was talking about music school
and going into the music industry i felt
like that required a lot of training
[Music]
it was i was surprised i really thought
that ruby was more of the the dead
giveaway she seemed really cool but also
she seemed millennial
you said you model too right yeah how
long have you been like doing that for
like a year or two now oh cool how do
you like it
it's pretty fun well have you seen i'm
curious have you seen beauty standards
change at all because i know that jet
like
gen z has done a really good job at like
breaking down barriers mm-hmm oh like
body positivity
yeah or just like like on like there's a
runway model that was pregnant like the
other week on like swimwear in miami
which was really dope so like they
haven't done that before you know what
i'm saying no no i'm so for that i like
it i like the body positivity ruby was
like coming after me like i was like oh
my god if she's coming after me then she
just must try to be like take attention
off herself when was everyone born you
don't have to say the year but like
march january oh we're in march march
7th march 11th hey pisces yeah that's
what's up
i love pisces september 25th libra cool
on september 17th so virgo oh
close oh i'm like
i didn't say that you all said your
placements i am a capricorn does anyone
want to ask someone someone asked
something please who is your favorite
pop star
what do you mean like like
i don't know
okay
[Music]
ryan's to my right and i hear this homie
read super loud i think he's just the
most suspicious at that point
i feel like she's just really trying to
put her info out there so no one
suspects her
[Music]
all right i'll see you guys later
you guys have fun please raise your hand
if you still have doubt that you caught
them all and want to continue playing
the game in three
two
one
okay i have a question
do you guys find that older generations
that you know like have a hard time
understanding gen z and like
our like new beliefs or whatever i think
what's really cool about gen z is that
since like we're all becoming so diverse
you know how we're obviously it's like
the generations are in like 20 year
ranges right so i think now with gen z i
think now we're kind of breaking that
down and just being like i think we're
more merging down into just like one
collective line if that makes sense yeah
i feel that too even like socially like
take for instance like during the
election time
um the whole trump thing when everyone
was like oh reserve tickets um to
trump's campaign or whatever so no one
would show up yeah i thought that was
brilliant and such a cool way for gen z
to like yeah
make our voice heard yeah i had a
question about your job so you do
nursing i'm not a nurse i recruit nurses
oh so you're also in recruiting yes okay
yes okay cool how did you get into
recruiting like a linkedin post i didn't
know what to do i had like this weird
like school situation um that i had to
deal with so i was like i had to like
change my path really quickly and so i'm
like oh ruby was talking a lot about
more adult stuff per se and she sounded
very
well spoken
and so i thought there was a possibility
that she is the mole have you done
anything big or anything like that yeah
i've done broadway and stuff oh my god
oh like broadway broadway yeah new york
that's really cool what was your
favorite one
i did elf the musical no way yeah
i play michael no buddy's little brother
i don't have anything else sorry i don't
know bro i just feel like i can't relate
to y'all because you're older than me
even though it's like two years i just
feel like it's still awkward and i'm
like oh okay
yeah
[Music]
he said he was into acting and i was
like okay then maybe you're acting right
now
[Music]
please
i was so disappointed because i thought
i did such a good job please raise your
hand if you still have doubt that you
caught them all and want to continue
playing the game
okay majority
doesn't want to continue so we will end
the game now
if the lights turn green that means you
have voted out the mall and you win if
the light turns red that means the mole
is still in the box and you lose
[Applause]
i was so in shock i did not think i was
going to win and i was just thinking i
was like everyone back home like i won
told you no i actually kind of believed
i wasn't going to win too but still will
the millennial please step forward and
reveal yourself in three
two
one
[Music]
i knew it i knew it i knew it i knew it
no idea
can i be honest yeah i voted you first
round and you want to know why why
because you're wearing cargo shorts oh
isn't that right
so i am actually a millennial i am 29
years old and i know that i look a lot
younger my nickname is babyface trace
because i have looked the same since i
was 16 years old i get carded every time
i buy alcohol i get carded in the exit
role of planes you need to be 16 to be
there i didn't even know that oh my god
so i can be my younger sister who is
actually 24 and is actually a music
teacher and i everything that i answered
was my younger sister gen z is very open
like i think gen z is like a very like
accepting what gen z is doing a really
good job of is breaking down barriers in
terms of it doesn't matter if you're 12
if you're 49 if you're 82 like we're all
going to find something in common and
break down those limits oh
my god
[Music]
for my pockets
i don't remember that was like a year
ago that was like yeah